I want people to be making the ethical
argument if a free trade as the supreme
instrument of poverty alleviation of
conflict resolution and of social
justice I am Nick Gillespie with Reason
TV and today we're talking with Daniel
Hannan he's a member of the European
Parliament for the time being and he was
also one of the people behind the brexit
one of the heads of vote leave Daniel
thanks for talking to thank you so what
is going on with brexit now England has
you know they passed a referendum and
we're out but nothing quite has moved on
since then
it's a two-year process until breaks it
formally takes effect and we're gonna
use those two years to try and scope the
kind of trade deals that we can have in
the rest of the world I mean the the EU
although it's an internal market is
actually a fairly protectionist body
visa vie non you know it's a single
largest economic trading zone they did
not create any agreements with outsiders
they have some generally with countries
that are either in the European area or
are usually French former territories in
North Africa but they don't have the big
trade deals China India United States
you know Indonesia Brazil
none of those and so this is our
opportunity if we can get this right you
know we've we've oshi a to leave a
protectionist customs union we now have
a chance to be a more deregulated more
global more free trading country and if
we get this right you can benefit
everybody it can be the thing that all
lifts the world back into a more open
trading system because frankly you're
not going to get that from Brussels and
I don't is there's any great enthusiasm
for it now in the White House so
somebody has got to be making the case
for freer trade and unrestrictedly yeah
and United States contacts both
Democrats and Republicans seem to be
pretty protectionist these days and it's
a reaction I think to the it's a delayed
reaction to the financial crisis people
have drawn exactly the wrong conclusion
but in a way understandably they say the
system was rigged with big corporates
and multinationals are profiting maybe
we should be kind of looking to
ourselves more which of course is
exactly the opposite right
I want people to be making the ethical
argument for free trade as the supreme
instrument of poverty alleviation of
conflict resolution and of social
justice and and that's because a when
you trade you gain for a bit both sides
gain if it's not ever selling freely its
moral but also what else has done so
much to lift our species to the current
levels of health and happiness I mean in
1990 38 % of human beings were living in
extreme poverty that is on a dollar a
day or less
now that figure is 8% why because
previously closed African and Asian
countries have joined the Nexus of
global trade the biggest paradox of our
age is that these idealistic young
people who go on occupy sit-ins or
protest g20 meetings or whatever have
somehow got it into their heads that by
opposing free trade they're standing up
for the poor against the multinationals
when in fact they're doing exactly the
opposite is the multinationals that
thrive on the distortions and the
tariffs and the quotas and it's the poor
who will benefit most from their removal
talk in in an American context the way
the bragg's of thought gets discussed
you know there's some of this and and
certainly you're the spokesman for that
and then it is usually discussed in a
way that is related to the Trump
phenomenon you know we'll talk about the
parallels between Briggs and Trump in a
bit but that it's it's really it's about
nativism it's about racism it's about
xenophobia it's about a fear traditional
historic fear of England being overrun
as the raglan nation by others yes where
is that wrong in the press room on every
level I mean even down to it being
traditional and historic I mean you
won't find a much more open country or
historically you know in both
commercially and and culturally you know
I've learned in politics that nobody
ever really listens to or reads anything
by the other side all they do is they
read their friends report of what the
other side is supposed to have said
right and if we really had fought a
nativist and protectionist campaign we
wouldn't have got into double figures
let alone winning you know you you win
because you carry people with a sense of
optimism and vision
there is more of a consensus for free
markets in Britain than probably in any
other large economy in the world you
know no one literally no one said we
should cut ourselves off from trade with
our European friends not as anyone by
the way want to stop being engaged with
allies on every continent but the
reality is the European Union is is
collapsing it's it's it's collapsing as
a share of world trade it's a 1950s
hangover its
dirige East it's top down we can do
better raising our eyes to you of the
movement of people because this is you
know I you know in Ireland they talk
about Polish people or you know
Slovakian is flooding the market and
things like that isn't that I mean what
was the role of the free movement of
work so they within the labor force
because there was some motion certain
about that but it's important that well
you know it's one of those things where
you can swap anecdotes or you can look
at the data all of the polls were very
clear that the biggest issue by far the
biggest issue was democracy or
sovereignty or however you honor taking
your own decisions immigration was a
very distant second and not everyone
citing immigration as their top concern
wanted a complete in fact I having
anyone would had a complete end to
immigration people wanted a sense of
some control and I think that's actually
a perfectly legitimate thing so what
would a controlled immigration flour
worker flow look like compared to the
openness of the EU which from a
classical liberal perspective
particularly in Europe barely out of you
know two world wars is kind of amazing
sure so I mean there is there is a
consensus behind certain kinds of
immigration being good 88% of people
want qualified and skilled workers from
the EU to continue to come to the UK
eighty-four percent of people want all
EU nationals currently in the UK skilled
or unskilled to be allowed to stay but
there were there were some very
contentious cases for example there was
a hate preacher called Abu Hamza
Islamist a preacher was eventually
deported his daughter was found guilty
of his rate his daughter-in-law was
found guilty of a criminal offence
incarcerated and then sentenced to
deportation and overturned the
deportation order in the European Court
even though she was a Jordanian national
because her son had been born
in the UK and this was held to violate
his rights as a European sister who have
his mother raised him something like
that the court's judgment said she is
the sole carer I think the implication
is that we the taxpayer are the sole
breadwinner as happens in these cases
now I think people very reasonably
perfectly legitimately said hang on for
an immigration policy to work you have
to be able to distinguish between you
know the person who's coming to be a
professor or a surgeon or whatever and
someone who is here living on benefits
and preaching a doctrine that is hostile
to the whole Western order if we're not
able to determine who we admit in whom
we keep out then we're in no sense a
democracy talk a bit about also wanted
that one of the main talk marks brexit
was ok these unelected bureaucrats were
dictating you know in faraway capitals
Brussels never we're dictating laws how
is that right because isn't it also the
case that the I mean you were elected to
represent England or Britain you go
there you pass a bunch of laws and then
they come back so is it is it that clear
so we have a now in 9% or 12% share over
the laws and that would be fine if we
felt there community of identity we felt
that we were part of the same people you
know in in the same way that you know my
constituency and people in Hampshire or
sorry except the UK but it does depend
on having that affinity people sometimes
say oh well but you know Idaho accepts
the jurisdiction of the federal
authorities yeah okay it's a bad choice
but well yeah we get that right but it's
what I say it's a bad choice unlike that
you know the real parallel here would be
if I were to say you should have a pan
american union with a Pan American
Parliament in Havana that would have
supremacy over your laws with a Pan
American central you know a Supreme
Court in Caracas that would be able to
strike down laws of Congress let's throw
in a pan-american central banking when I
was iris that administers your new
currency the pan-american peso that
would be the fair parallel and of course
you know how how that would be people
would tell me to buzz off if I they
might
struggle with so do you see the you
talked about the collapse of the U or
the failure and it's clear that you know
with both with it
Britain leaving but other countries are
talking about it there's economic
difficulties you know and you called it
a hangover from the 1950s from the
Common Market days does it represent you
know it was the lat rather than being a
new beginning for Europe it's the last
gasp of that old kind of nineteen
twentieth-century
centralized control model everything
everything in our lives is becoming more
dispersed more decentralized whereas in
Europe will again correct I think the us
in one sense was incredibly lucky in the
timing of its foundation the
Constitution was drawn up at the moment
when there was the maximum emphasis in
Western thought on the liberty of the
individual and constraints on state
power ask the question whether the bill
of rights would get through Congress
today sadly the European Union is also a
child of its time it was born at a time
when there was a huge belief in the
power of beneficent government and when
the whole model was kind of was top-down
and D reduced so built into the
foundations of the EU are a collectivist
agricultural system common external
tariff s-- industrial policy and indeed
government by as you said unelected
people because it was thought that
democracy was a bit dangerous people get
the wrong ideas an efficient right so
you should have these wise technocrats
who would disinterested an immune to
public opinion as you say the world has
moved on now is the alternative though
and particularly in Europe and you see
this these kinds of flashpoints
happening certainly during the early
years of the EU in the 90s and whatnot
of you know it's either Europe is either
unified or its balkanized and people
start shooting at each other again are
those the only two options there's a
really good extant third option which is
the European free trade association the
European free trade association is a
classical free trade area it's much more
like NAFTA than like the European Union
that is it doesn't really busy itself
with behind border issues
it sets common standards when you're
trading rather than when you're not
and it it's based on mutual recognition
of products rather than standardized
rules pretty good model and of course it
has no aspirations to political union
now I hope that Britain will have that
kind of relationship with other
countries in Europe based in a
continuing common market but without an
external tariff so we'll be able to sign
a free trade with you with Canada and so
on
there will be some countries in Europe
that for whatever historical reasons are
still wedded to the ideal of
federalization centralization great let
them I mean isn't the ideal outcome from
here that you try and create a pan
continental market that stretches from
you know Iceland to Turkey a likely but
effectively regulated common market open
to the rest of the world encompassing I
don't know 40 45 countries states and
territories and then within that shore
have 20 25 countries that want their
single currency their single president
their single foreign policy good likes
them doesn't that let everybody get on
better growth at the peripheral
countries get the common market which is
what they came for their core countries
can push ahead how does the brags that
complicate something like NATO or the
military alliances throughout Western
Europe or the developed world because it
seems that while there is a groundswell
of support for for brexit there's also
you know more of a bigger need for a
unified European defence against Russia
or whatever as a matter of fact during
the campaign a decision was made to
deploy UK personnel to the defence of
Poland in Estonia and nobody criticized
that decision nobody on either side try
to press it into the referendum argument
or make a big issue out of why are our
guys defending a faraway country there
was a consensus if this was the right
thing to do
similarly during the campaign we took a
decision to deploy naval resources to
help with a migration crisis in the
Mediterranean and nobody criticized it
so Britain has not voted for
disengagement that those those things
are almost uniformly supported and our
commitment to NATO remains I think that
the the critics of NATO in the US have
won
good point which is that the burden has
to be fairly shared minoo the US has a
20 trillion dollar debt Meili and it has
to pick and choose what is overseas
commitments going to be and it does seem
unfair to expect the u.s. to bear the
burden of European defense when all it
gets back are insults and sarcastic
comments you know so I think that that's
a good argument to be having well
speaking of Trump who made a similar
argument what are the parallels between
the dynamics behind brexit and the
election of Donald Trump here if there
are any I mean it's presumed that and
you know Trump himself and not Nigel
Farage have had said there's common
enemy I guess even even campaign for him
up there so there I mean it's so we've
said that there is this big difference
you know a big part of Trump stick
insofar as I understand it was we don't
want a free trade agreement with China a
huge part of our campaign we do owe with
TPP right but a huge part of us was we
do want to trade agree on of the EU
won't let us have one you know we're
gonna be up so so you know we can overdo
this what I think the two phenomena did
have in common I suppose inescapably was
a sense of anger against what was seen
to be a failing political elite and I
think that sense of anger has really
been mounting ever since the crash and
the bailouts I think there's been a
widespread sense on both sides of the
Atlantic that the the response to the
financial crisis to the credit crunch
was to penalize low and medium income
families in order to rescue some very
wealthy bankers and bondholders from the
consequences of their own error and in a
way Trump and Sanders and a number of
the protest parties in Europe are all
kind of delayed responses to what
happened in 2008-2009
that said you know the way that you
address people's concerns is not simply
by reflecting their anger back at them
or amplifying their their sense of
grievance the way you address their
concerns is to tackle the problem of
certain groups being left behind and I
think one very obvious
where you can do that is to change the
monetary policy that your central your
Fed and our Bank of England and the
European Central Bank the Bank of Japan
have all been doing which is this
constant splurge of quantitative easing
which has led to an asset price
inflation which has indeed penalized the
unskilled workers and that's something
very easily fixed and would I think go a
long way to addressing people's sense of
unfairness what is there do you think
that this is a struck you know we've
we've reached a new part of history and
there's economists in the u.s. they talk
about this well welcome to two percent
annual north if we're lucky the years of
3% 4% 5% are over so that we really need
to manage the the scant resources that
we have is that myopic or I think we
thought like that in the 70s in Britain
yeah that it was over it was over the
phrase was managed to decline it's a
question of how civilized away can we do
this you know
and there were apparently rational
reasons for thinking that you know we
had constant strikes we had double-digit
inflation that we had it also broken up
right prices and incomes policies I mean
a Conservative government passing laws
and what you were allowed to earn and
what you were allowed to set your prices
had it was a completely reasonable thing
to think we're finished but of course we
didn't realize then that we were on the
verge of a great national Renaissance
under Margaret Thatcher
so I actually I'm very optimistic about
this country and about the long-term
future of it I think the the
individualistic and dispersed political
and legal institutions of the u.s. it
very very well for prosperity in this
century and I see a great future with a
weak driverless cars and advances in
biotech and 3d printing and all sorts of
things based on innovation because the
innovators were always several steps
ahead of regulators they're always
clever perhaps talk a bit about both in
Europe as well as in the United States
there's there is a fear that with a kind
of
populist uprising against established
powers which I think we would agree is a
good thing
nativist sentiments racialist sentiments
come in and we already see I mean on the
Left people hold on to racial categories
ethnic categories gender categories very
much so they don't want to let those go
and on the right you're seeing that in
the United States the alt-right talks
about a white nationalism that really
hasn't been heard from since the late
60s or early 70s in the United States is
that a concern for you either in England
or in the US or across the developed
world where it seems like you know
things are breaking down along racial
ethnic lines in a way that's troubling
I'm not sure how true that is it's it's
natural to become alarmed about people
saying extreme things even if their
numbers of time grow if you spend your
life on Twitter you think the old right
is a very big deal but how many times do
you hear any normal person raising it in
the real world rather than virtually
right funnily enough I just had a
meeting with the behavioral psychologist
Jonathan Haight brilliant brilliant
writer who I think I think his work is
at the most it's the most important
cutting-edge work being done in terms of
understanding what drives our political
sympathies and his point was that
actually most of this sentiment is not
about race or categorization by you know
ethnicity gender and so on but is about
a sense of being insulted having your
values traduced in other words being
called a racist all the time and that
that's created a backlash from people
who are not in any sense races now of
course there is a minority of racist
numbskulls in your country in mine and
in every other event but that but I
think we should keep a sense of
proportion the backlash is not really
driven by the people who have jumped
onto it it's it's driven by a sense that
a elites used a crony ax stand
co-operative system to enrich themselves
at public expense and then be that
having done that they turned around and
spat on the values of the people who'd
bailed them out
for Trump and you you've written
recently into Washington Washington
Examiner not that you are warming up to
Trump and that he's your D thawing
towards him yeah
what are what are the early indicators
that will make you think okay this guy
is heading in the right direction word
now this we got a you know there's a
real problem well I guess it by the time
people watch this video they'll have a
better idea of what the administration
then as I'm talking to you but obviously
that's going to be the first earlier
sign from hearing the speculation I do
find quite encouraging actually I think
is some really good names you're out
there you know I was never that worried
about I think some of the hysteria it's
not just sort of self-indulgent and and
solipsistic it it kind of totally misses
the point about the American
Constitution your founders had someone
very like Donald Trump in mind when they
designed all these checks and balances
the capacity of Hillary Clinton and like
Hillary Clinton exactly even the most
Caligula and president is constrained my
guess is that there is basically a kind
of anti Trump majority in both houses
now there were lots of Republicans
elected who didn't really hide their
views of him and that that provides a
constraint and I think he you know maybe
I'm wrong and we'll see how he works out
but I mean he is somebody who at least
understands about deal-making and
understands about when a deal can't be
done and how you should then make the
best of it all right well we will leave
it there we've been talking with Daniel
Hannan he is a member of the European
Parliament and he was one of the main
people behind brexit co-founder of the
vote leave group Daniel thanks for
talking too much for recent TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]